today on the matt welsh show the left
continues to eat itself as a gay rights
organization that had been around for 50
years voluntarily dissolves and disbands
after blm criticized it
this is a convoluted but also
instructive not to mention hilarious
story we'll talk about it today also
five headlines including olivia
rodrigo's trip to the white house to
promote vaccines raising the question
for many people
who is olivia rodrigo and speaking of
blm they have finally spoken out about
the situation in cuba
in order to defend the cuban government
of course and a state representative
in minnesota says that he was racially
profiled during a traffic stop but the
body cam footage shows something else
entirely
and in our daily cancellation we will
wade into the murky confused and toxic
waters
of abortion tick-tock all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now a word from my photo you know
everywhere i go
uh i am hounded by the paparazzi that's
just
that's that's that's how it is to be a
podcast host uh only the paparazzi in
this case is uh just my wife
because she's everywhere we go and
everything we do she wants to take
pictures and uh i have a few problems
with that but
one of my number one problems is that we
take all these pictures and then they
they just stay on a phone and they don't
we don't do anything with them
and i think that's the case for most
people a lot of wasted pictures which is
why you need
my photo you're taking all these
pictures well how about what are you
going to do to actually cherish those
moments how about making it physical
so that moment that you captured doesn't
just get lost on your camera roll
that's why you got to check out my photo
it is it's awesome it's easy to use it
takes literally two minutes to create a
special product for your own wall or
shelf
whatever you want to do with it they
also make great gifts for your loved
ones
my photo prints your image directly on
acrylic glass metal and much more
so don't just leave it on your phone go
to my photo uh you need to go to
myphoto.com and check it out that's
myphoto.com order today you'll get 20
off your order which will arrive in just
five days prices start at just 12
use code walsh and get 20 off today at
myphoto.com
something that those on the of us on the
right always enjoy
and derive immense satisfaction from
somewhat sick satisfaction perhaps but
satisfaction nonetheless
are stories of the left turning on
itself and its adherence devouring
each other as they are prone do we've
seen this phenomenon many times and
i think it might be interesting and
useful to try and figure out
why this happens exactly but before we
do that let's look at the latest example
and it's a it's a rather
glorious example i must say boston pride
is the group that organizes the city's
pride parade and
other gay activities in the city it's
important to note that this organization
has been around
and active for 50 years okay
um they so presumably one of the oldest
you know gay rights organizations i
would assume in the country
they've been um major significant
players
in the gay rights world and and and yet
recently they'd had come under fire from
within their own ranks
a growing number of lgbt activists
decided that boston pride
is racist because there are too many
white people running the organization
and too many white people attending the
events
now i have no interest in at all in
defending boston pride
but i do feel compelled to point out
that boston pride
would naturally tend to be white simply
because boston the city
is predominantly white unlike many other
cities today like say baltimore which is
uh
62 black in boston the majority of
residents are white
just so happens making it not so
shocking or scandalous that a majority
of boston pride attendees
are white there are many other
scandalous things that happen at those
events no doubt
but that isn't one of them nonetheless
you can't have too many white people as
we have learned
or too many quote cisgender people which
was another problem apparently
and that's why local activists this past
year after
uh attacking boston pride as racist and
even transphobic
decided to boycott the traditional event
the traditional pride event that i've
been going on for 50 years and hold
their own
so this past month on june 12th uh 12th
you may have missed this i'm sorry if
you did but they had their first annual
trans resistance march and vigil led by
they said
queer and trans people of color an
article posted to
boston.com last month explains the
reasoning for this competing event
it says queer trans and black indigenous
people of color
by poc activists have been calling on
boston pride to make changes since at
least 2015 when black lives matter
demanded the organization diversify the
board
allow bi-poc activists control of black
and latino pride events
and re-examine corporate sponsorships
among other things last summer numerous
boston pride volunteers
resigned after the organization
allegedly removed a statement supporting
black lives matter from a newsletter
and called for all board members to step
down in place of more representative
leadership
according to boston globe boston pride's
six-member six-members board has no
black members
two latino members and one transgender
member
quote my experience in working with the
board is they experience
um is community voices as antagonistic
as opposed to thinking these are our
people this according to joe
triglio who resigned from the boston
pride communications team
telling the globe quote they treat that
as some sort of attack as opposed to
what it is people asking them to serve
their needs and interests
only one transgender board member at a
six outrageous
now we know of course that trans people
comprise far less than one percent of
the population
but they must in any case comprise at
least 50 percent
of every organization board committee
panel
and television show cast how can that
even be possible i mean how can you take
so few trans people
and spread them so widely and visibly
well that's your problem figure it out
you have to be like jesus multiplying
the loaves and fishes
multiply the trans let's say you got to
figure out a way to do it
whatever you need to do get it done the
point is simply that this tiny fraction
of the population
must be seen everywhere all the time
without exception
and boston pride they failed in that
regard just as they failed by
allowing too many white people to
participate
and that's what ultimately led to this
as nbc reports today after 50 years boss
of pride is disbanding and dissolving
itself in shame
for the sin of being too white and also
two
not trans this according to nbc it says
quote
boston pride the organization that has
organized the city's pride celebrations
for 50 years has announced it is
shutting down
the dissolution announced friday
afternoon in a statement on the group's
website
comes after the reportedly all-white
board of directors has faced ongoing
accusations of ignoring racial
minorities and transgender people
it is clear to us that our community
needs and wants change without the
involvement of boston pride the board
said in statement
we have heard the concerns of the qtbi
boc community and others uh
the qt bipot community to others the
statement continued referring to queer
and transgender people of color
we care too much to stand in the way
therefore boston pride is dissolving
there will be no further events or
programming planned
and the board is taking steps to close
down the organization the board said the
decision quote was made with a heavy
heart
out of love and hope for a better future
now you might be thinking this is
hilarious
and great bunch of left-wing gay
activists just nuked our own
organization for no reason at all
what's not to love and you're right it
is indeed hilarious and great but aside
from pointing and laughing it might as i
said be instructive to talk about
why this sort of thing happens because
it happens a lot
and to that end i think there are three
factors to consider
the first is this very simply um blm
exercises complete and total power on
the left
and they know it nobody on that side of
the ideological divide
will oppose them or whisper the
slightest objection
even as blm swoops in and eviscerates
its own allies for no discernible reason
leftists have already set the precedent
that opposing black lives matter
the organization means opposing black
lives matter
the concept now usually the left can
violate its own precedence at will
one standard for us another standard for
them but this is one
that even they have to abide by even
they can't get away with violating this
standard
two there's the victim hierarchy now as
as we know by now
victimhood is power on the left which
means that there is a constant struggle
within its own ranks
to claim the status of uber victim
that's why the top spot on the victim
pyramid has changed hands several times
over the years
especially in recent years as one group
and then another plants its flag there
as it stands right now the coveted
territory
belongs to bipoc as they now call
themselves black and indigenous people
of color
but it's not enough to be just black or
indigenous
the top of the top the ultimate power
spot belongs to those who can add
additional identities especially
sexualized identities
which has given rise to now qtbipoc or
queer and trans black indigenous people
of color
boston pride was a mere lgbt
organization
they didn't they didn't make a move to
innovate and become a qtbi poc
lgbt organization and as such have been
left in the dust
a tragic tale as old as time three i
think most importantly
um and the most fundamental reason why
you see the left eat itself in this way
so often
is that the entire ideology is
intentional
intensely and almost solely self-focused
there cannot be any true community as
much as they talk about community
and they have so many different
communities
um and they talk about things like being
an
ally or ally ship that can't exist
camaraderie loyalty none of that exists
because they're all looking constantly
back within themselves i mean to be
a member of a real community to have
real camaraderie and loyalty
you have to look outward you have to be
concerned about
something other than just yourself
but they aren't that's the defining
feature of leftism it's an ideology a
religion
of the self
that is what it is at its core at its
base
and it's how they come up with all these
new self identities and why they believe
the whole world should cooperate with
and affirm whatever new identities they
invent
it's how we end up with um here's the
latest uh
it's how we end up with with nonsense
like this watch
so i'm not an expert or an authority on
what neural queer means
but to simplify it and make it easier
for you to understand it's essentially
um on a base level it's kind of where
your
neurodivergent identity and your queer
identity how they
interact and intersect this also extends
to your other identities such as your
race
your socioeconomic class your ethnicity
and how those things also interact and
intersect with your neurodivergence
and your queerness and some ways that
some people may practice being
neuroqueer can range from
theoretical thought experiments to
social justice work methods
a good example may be something like
deciding to
represent your gender identity in an
intentionally
queer way as a way to subvert hegemonic
ideas of gender performance
is a fairly new term so it is very fluid
and the possibilities are endless
oh well okay uh subvert hegemonic ideas
of gender performance
she says with piercings in her cheek
now indeed though the possibilities are
endless as she says
neuroqueer why not just another identity
to add to the list
nothing you just heard there there was
not a coherent sentence uttered
throughout that that whole 56 seconds
um this though is what happens
this is another identity invented by
someone who spends almost all of her
time
staring back into the abyss of her own
ego
according to her religion the leftist
religion which is also our state
religion by the way
nothing matters so much as how you feel
and it's not just how you feel it's
another thing that i think people on the
right get wrong
well on the left they're always they're
so sensitive they're focused on their
feelings
well let's be more specific it's not how
you feel it's about how you feel about
yourself your feelings about yourself
everything comes back to yourself
now in a weird way this is what makes
leftism alluring
and powerful especially when it comes to
kids and teenagers it's one of the
reasons why
so many kids and teenagers gravitate in
that direction
because they tend already to be
self-focused everyone has that
capacity that inclination that instinct
towards uh egotism and narcissism
but it's also what makes leftism
dysfunctional and volatile and prone to
self-sabotage
and although all of this is very bad for
the country and our future
as a civilization and our species it is
also sometimes at least
as is the case with this boston pride
story extremely funny
now let's get to our five headlines
you know i'm always telling you about
rockauto.com because they're just
the best option that you have available
to you if you need auto parts
rather than going to the store and
dealing with all that you can just go to
rockauto.com
and uh what's you know what's the best
thing about rockauto.com for me
there's of course there's the
convenience of it that you have it
available on your phone or your computer
there's the really low prices
as a cheap skate myself and a vow cheap
skate that's that's an aspect i really
personally enjoy um but the thing that i
like most about it when i've gone to
rockauto.com is that's very easy
to navigate and you can find exactly
what you're looking for
um you don't have to know a lot about
cars you don't have to be tech savvy
which is good for me because i'm neither
of those things but you can go and you
can find
everything you need all you're doing is
you're just you're plugging in your
your vehicle is whatever brand you want
specifications the prices you prefer
and you can have it all laid out there
for you and you can't do that at the
auto parts store you know it's not that
simple the auto parts store but you can
do that at rockauto.com so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and we want credit for it so as always
remember to write walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
all right so first of all
olivia rodrigo was at the white house
yesterday and uh one question i've seen
a lot
in relation to this and she was there to
talk about vaccines we'll play the clip
in a second
if you're wondering what olivia
rodrigo's opinion is on vaccines
but one question that's popped up a lot
in relation to this is uh
is who the hell is olivia rodrigo and
i'm i'm
you know usually i'm like everyone else
and this is how one of the ways i know
that i'm old i mean i've been old
since i was born really i was born this
way um but
one of the ways i know that i'm old is
it that i don't know
so many famous people and i that i have
no idea who they are anymore
uh olivia rodrigo i do know who she is
because we did a youtube video about her
reviewing one of her one of her great
one of her great songs
i use the word great very loosely here
um
so i know that she's a pop star i can
tell you that this is how
in touch i am with the youth this one i
know
she's a pop star i think she originated
with uh was it tick tock
or like an instagram or something and
then she was that was that somebody else
i'm thinking of or she was disney she
came either disney or tick tock that's
that's kind of the farm team
for the pop stars these days and um
anyway so she was at the white house and
first can we just show
the cli here she is walking in i just
want to show you this picture of her
walking into the white house
in those shoes there i don't i don't
even know how you move in those shoes i
also didn't realize that those shoes
were were back in style these platform
shoes i thought that was like
so that's back in style now i guess it's
also been reported
um jack basobia reported on twitter
that jill biden there's a little bit of
contention now in the white house
because jill biden dr joe biden i should
say
excuse me thought apparently according
to anonymous sources
thought that olivia rodrigo's shoes were
not appropriate for the event
and i just think if she did say that
rushing to the defense of olivia rodrigo
here as a big fan of hers
i mean that coming from jill biden of
all people
who are you to talk might i remind you
of that uh dress that she wore
a few weeks ago looked like it's was
stitched together from various like
drapery
around around the white house they just
tore they just tore curtains down in
drapes
around the white house and just stitched
it together
some schizophrenic person stitched
together and put it on her
and she has the audacity to accuse
people of
lacking a fashion sense anyway that's
not really the important part the
important part is olivia
rodrigo is there to tell us about
vaccines and here she is
it's important to have conversations
with friends and family members
encouraging all communities to get
vaccinated
and actually get to a vaccination site
which you can do more easily than
ever before given how many sites we have
and how easy it is to find them at
vaccines.gov
well there it is olivia rodrigo has
spoken so
they're going door to door they're
bribing you
they're they're beating you over the
head perhaps literally in some cases
um doing everything they can and if
you're still not convinced well here's
olivia rodrigo pop star
and if that doesn't convince you i don't
know what will they have juvenile
vax that ass up what else do they have
to do
to get you to put this substance into
your body
all right next uh black lives matter
speaking of which
they put out a statement finally on the
situation
down in cuba and they had been
basically silent about it until now
and the statement is rather lengthy i'm
not going to read the entire thing
but it will shock you to to learn that
black lives matter they've looked at
what's happening down in cuba
people protesting the tyranny of the
communist government
and black lives matter has decided they
know who's at fault
uh america is at fault it's our fault
it's our government not theirs
so this is their statement in part it
says black lives matter condemns the u.s
federal government's inhumane treatment
of cubans
and uh not not the cuban government
according to reports i mean they're
they're right now killing protesters
black lives matter speaking up and
saying we condemn the inhumane treatment
of these protesters
by the u.s federal government
this cruel and inhumane policy
instituted with the explicit intention
of destabilizing the country and
undermining cubans right to
choose their own government is at the
heart of cuba's current crisis
since 1962 this united states has forced
pain and suffering on the people of cuba
by cutting off food medicine and
supplies costing the tiny island nation
an estimated
130 billion dollars without that money
it is harder for cuba to
acquire medical equipment needed to
develop its own coven 19 vaccines and
equipment for food production
this comes in spite of the country's
strong medical care and history of
lending doctors and nurses
to disasters around the world the people
of cuba are being punished
by the u.s government
being murdered by their own government
but but no the real punishment is from
us
because the country has maintained its
commitment to sovereignty and
self-determination
this is not just attacking the united
states
this is a full-throated defense of the
communist
cuban government never mind that much of
what's being said here is just
factually wrong simply not true much of
it
but it's a defense of of the cubic and
of course it is
what else are they going to say their
communist organization
avowedly so
and they also have no problem
they don't have any problem with
violence clearly it doesn't bother them
that people are being killed they
certainly don't value human life
all they care is about the the is about
power their own power number
first and foremost and the end
ideological goal
that's all they care about now i have
noticed
um there's been a lot of criticism of
black lives matter for this statement
which is good they deserve to be
criticized for it
have you even noticed some conservatives
conservative commentators and so on
uh coming out pretty strong against
black lives matter for this
again well deserved fine but some of
those
some of those commentators as far as i
could tell this is the first time
they've come out strong against black
lives matter
you know i'm old enough to remember like
i don't know nine months ago
up to nine months ago or even more
recently
where if you criticize black lives
matter and called them what they are
an extremist communist organization a
terrorist organization
[Music]
many different many descriptions would
fit the bill here
but you you'd be attacked as racist not
just by the left
but even by some people on the right
you know this is what frustrates me
it's one of the reasons why black lives
matter
got to this point of being as powerful
as they are
because for years they've been doing
this for a while now
going back to ferguson and even slightly
before that
and for years people on the right
many of them either kept silent refused
to criticize them
or would actively defend them and say no
they're just concerned with racial
justice
meanwhile blm from its inception
this is why there is no excuse for
people that were that oblivious
in fact i don't believe that they were
that oblivious i think they were just
cowardly
but from their inception this has been a
a an organization drenched in blood
and violence and deception
violence and deception has been their mo
from
from
the beginning
and it took uh it took years
for for it to be sort of a mainstream
thing on
on among conservatives to openly
criticize blm
and that's pathetic and now finally this
appears to be the last straw for for a
lot of people which
great why'd it take you so long
let's move here so the freedom fighters
as they're being called now are still in
dc those are the texas democrats who
fled the state
uh and now they're being branded anyway
by amy klobuchar
as freedom fighters and she said this
almost with a straight
face she almost accomplished sang it
with a straight face here's a clover
chart
with these people of course with
freedom fighters who came
to washington dc to seek salvation
because they are not going to be able to
get that governor of texas
to protect the voting rights of the
people of texas we know that
in fact instead of trying to make it
easier for people
to vote the governor and
the republicans in the legislature have
done everything to make it harder
including threatening these legislators
over and over again and they are
standing
their ground just as we are scanning our
ground
freedom fighters seeking salvation
uh of course that's nauseating
and you know i said when all this first
started a few days ago
that uh it's hard for me to even
be angry at the texas democrats for
doing this
because they're doing the kind of thing
that i wish republicans would do
far more often which is playing hardball
and and and using the power that you
have
and also absolutely refusing
to give the other side anything that's
the thing about democrats they are not
going to give you
an inch they will not give you anything
at all
um and that's what's happening here with
these with these democrats
it doesn't make them heroes at all of
course right
they want they're they're taking a you
know a vacation paid for by the
taxpayers
they got their miller light and they're
on this little jaunt in dc they're being
celebrated and hailed as heroes
everywhere they go
which means they're not heroes
but it's hard for me to be mad at them
for doing it for that reason i know
most conservatives are pretty upset
about it and i'm saying to myself
all right i i get the play i understand
the play it's a smart play i guess
but they they do have the advantage of
course
that they've got the whole media on
their side
they have the whole establishment on
their side they've got all of our
cultural institutions on their side and
you have to remember that as well
so i i am constantly criticizing
republicans and i'll continue to
criticize them
for compromising way too much and by
compromising
it's not even really a compromise
usually when republicans do it because a
compromise means
uh i give up some of the stuff that that
i want and you give up some of the stuff
that you want and then we meet in the
middle
but with republicans the compromise is
i'll give up everything
and get nothing and just let you do
whatever you want
but you also have to keep in mind not to
excuse republicans at all
um they don't have all of our cultural
institutions on their side the way the
democrats do so it's a lot easier for
the democrats to do this kind of thing
and all that to say it doesn't make any
of this any less nauseating
to hear them hailed as freedom fighters
seeking salvation and speaking of
nauseating
i i i i cannot let you escape having to
listen to this
uh this was a couple of days ago all
those same texas democrats
were out in front of the capitol and
they uh spontaneously broke out into
song
and it's it's way worse than you even
could imagine that it would be
let's listen i turn it back over to you
for the questions
and uh thank you very much for all that
you
and all of your colleagues are doing
here today we will overcome
we will overcome we will
[Music]
thank you miss t thank you members of
congress
uh we'll take a few questions
oh my gosh they sound like a
bucket of cats falling over a waterfall
or something
that is
one of the worst musical performances
i've ever heard i feel kind of bad for
the two guys in the front there
because they didn't know that was going
to happen you could tell they didn't
know that was going to happen and now
they're stuck having to sing and they're
and they're the ones right in front of
the microphone
and you can tell they're doing the lip
sync thing a little bit
um but this is the they
well they're they're freedom fighters
singing we shall overcome
it's a it's a very awkward performance
let's just say that they're putting in
here
playing the part of quote freedom
fighters but they don't have to play it
convincingly because again they got the
media on their side
all right next state representative john
thompson of minnesota was
pulled over a couple of weeks ago
in saint paul and surprise
surprise he immediately decided that he
was uh
racially profiled and i don't know how
well we can hear this but here he is at
he was that he was uh he was pulled over
this is on i don't know july
5th or 6th and uh and then a few days
later he attended a memorial for
philando castile
and that is where i think he first
shared his harrowing tale of being
racially profiled supposedly by the
police
let's listen to that profile for these
two
matter of fact i was just pulling over
saturday your pretext will stop and
you know you don't have a front license
plate and i got a ticket
for my license anyway i thought we
weren't doing pretext would stop scaring
that thing
listen but we are yeah that's so we
clear still getting driving while black
tickets here
in this state that's back in st paul yo
so
let's just call it what it is that's
right
but they turn deadly you know these
these traffic stops turn
deadly you know cause i'm in my car with
this baseball hat yo
and you can't tell i'm the state
representative john thompson neither
should i have to
to change my clothes that's right that
part this song
i'm a minnesota state representative i'm
a lawmaker here i could wear what i
wanted with that's right you have to be
profiled
that part ridiculous yo it was by the
way the sergeant here in saint paul
okay so he was pulled over um as you
heard him
describe there uh saying it was a
pretextual
stop and uh basically racially profiling
they're just looking for an excuse
because they saw according to him they
saw a black man in a car
with a hat on and they said uh let's
let's
pull him over i guess his his claim
what's being claimed here
is that what cops every time they see a
black guy in a car they just
automatically pull him over
because there's there's a problem there
because
you know if if that's how you operated
as a police officer in saint paul
you'd never be able to do anything else
aside from just
pull over black drivers it's just kind
of an absurd claim now he got pulled
over because
he would had didn't have a front license
plate you're supposed to have a front
license plate
um you could say it's a ticky tack thing
they get pulled over for that
okay maybe it is we see we could have a
conversation
about cops pulling people over on ticky
tack things
you know you get pulled over given a
ticket because your
you know headlight is out or something
there's an argument for that as well
because that's a safety issue
but we could talk about that police
officers spending far
too much time on this kind of thing
are there more important things they
could be doing are there other things
that they themselves would probably
prefer to be doing
that's a that's a perfectly reasonable
conversation
the problem is that th that conversation
gets totally drowned out
by all the racial rhetoric because it
has to become a racial issue
never mind the fact that i myself
have gotten pulled over because i've
gotten pulled over for that exact reason
actually
not having a front license plate
depending on the state you're in
um you know in in tennessee you don't
have to have front license plate but
depending on the state you're in that's
you're supposed to have one i've been
pulled over for that
and yeah it was kind of annoying why are
you bothering me about this does it
really matter
who even cares if i have a front license
plate
but it's the law the cops enforcing it i
was respectful
that was it it was the interaction was
over in in
five minutes and i went about my day
i didn't try to escalate it into
something else
because i didn't want it to turn into
anything else i just wanted to get back
to my day
that's it i didn't want this to be a
thing
but representative john thompson decided
to make it into a thing and
uh and then there was a big controversy
that around this and finally st
paul police chief todd axtell uh he
decided to fight back
you know he said he was going to look
into it and he did
and then he came out and said that this
the whole stop was by the books
it was completely fine nothing
inappropriate happened at all
and he was pulled over because he didn't
have the front license plate and then
they found out that he was driving on a
suspended license as well
um and then they also and the police
chief
not only explained this but he demand he
is now demanding an apology
from the state representative which is
exactly see going on the offense that is
the that's the right approach
it's one thing to be defensive and say
hey gee we looked into it and no i don't
think that
our officer did anything wrong that's
one thing
you got to go a step further and say no
nothing wrong
there was nothing bad that happened here
you know it
okay you're defaming this person you
need to apologize you're the bad guy
here
that's what the police chief is doing to
his credit he also released the body cam
footage
and uh the whole thing it's it's raw
footage like 15 minutes long
nothing of note happens except for at
the very end
when representative um thompson
starts claiming to the police officer
that he's being racially profiled
here's what happened there
i'm too old to run from the police man
you profile me because you look me dead
in the face and i got a ticket for
driving while black
you pulled me over because you saw a
black face in this car brother and you
and i was nowhere here i'm taking off
with you behind me
you looked at me in this car you looked
in this car and busted you turned and
got behind my car
and that's the reason why i know i know
but what i'm saying is what you're doing
is wrong to black men
and you need to stop that thank you so
much but this ticket means nothing to me
no
no no no i'm gonna always have a great
day what i'm saying you would stop
racially profiling black men in their
cars sir
stop doing that yes you were yes you
were yes you were
bro you you saw black man driving this
stops and i
there's no way he could be convinced
otherwise because what we're told now is
this is where we're at um according to
blm and guys like representative tom
thompson there
any time a police off officer pulls over
a black person it's racial profiling
doesn't matter the reason
every single time
you know it's it's an unfalsifiable
claim
he's waving the ticket around saying hey
you're ticking me for for driving while
black no i did i
the ticket is for not having a front
license plate i've given out a lot of
tickets for that the white and black
people
you don't like that law or that rule
take it up with your legislator you are
a legislator
maybe you should pass a law or something
if you don't like that rule
that's that's the great irony here that
i almost missed until just right now
a lot of times the problem that you
think you have with the police it's not
with the police it's with the people
making these
laws if you don't want the police
enforcing these laws
take it up with the people who made them
cops are not are not law makers they're
law enforcers
and so if you don't think that there's
ever an appropriate time for a police
officer to pull
a black man over on a on a charge like
that
that charge shouldn't exist
all right finally i wanted to mention
this very briefly
um if we have time usa today
story here uh i i don't think there's
ever been a time when lots of people in
media have been freaking out about some
gun related thing and i find myself
agreeing with them
but today is the exception and i'm not
freaking out i should say so it's not
full agreement but i agree with the
criticism i have to say there's
so there's first time for everything so
here's the um the thing that has
prompted the backlash
much of it from the anti-gun crowd and
it's a gun it's a real gun you can see
the picture there
a real functional gun made to look like
a lego toy so here's a story from usa
today they say a utah-based gun company
faces backlash this week
after selling a glock handgun a handgun
casing that transforms the weapon to
look like a children's lego toy
the gun company culpa precision agreed
to remove the product from its website
and not make or sell anything like this
in the future
after lego reached out according to a
statement from lego to usa today
the block 19 kick which uh borrows from
lego's characteristic red blue and
yellow
brick design debuted last week with a
website set website page touting it as
it as
super fun the site said quote this is
just one small way to break the rhetoric
from anti-gun folks and draw attention
to the fact
that the shooting sports that the
shooting sport is
super fun um here's the thing guns are
fun shooting is fun
30 rounds full auto is fun
and uh this was supposed to
this was supposed to what break the
rhetoric from the anti-gun crowd
no you've just given them ammunition so
to speak
in an almost literal way
this this this will really show the
anti-gun crowd what's what
and then a few days later you're taking
the thing off
in shame yeah this is a stupid and
horrible idea
um and i don't need to give you the
whole disclaimer about how
i'm a gun owner and a second amendment
absolutist and all that because i am
and you already know that but it's in
part because i'm a gun owner and i take
this stuff seriously that i hate this so
much
first of all guns are not toys okay yeah
it's fun to go shoot
shooting is a fun hobby collecting guns
is fun all that stuff is fun nothing
wrong with that stuff being fun
it's still not a toy though um it's a
weapon
and yes it's up to you to practice good
gun safety keep your weapons locked up
and all of that out of reach of children
but to go out of your way to
intentionally make a gun
enticing to small children to
intentionally purposely make it look
like a toy to kids
that's inexcusable and there's no reason
to do it the only reason to do it is is
it looks cool and it doesn't by the way
it looks gaudy and hideous
but looking cool doesn't outweigh the
downside which is pretty severe
and by the way speaking of police
officers if gum if gun companies were to
go in this direction and start making
guns that look like this
now you've just made a cops job a
thousand times harder
and now you put them in an even more
impossible situation
and you put a lot of potentially
innocent people in danger including kids
so horrible idea
and i'm glad they took it down all right
let's move on now to reading the youtube
comments
um
let's see i'll go here first
free t-spirit says uh
referring to the he's referring to the
video of the man trying to breastfeed
which we played yesterday
so this is a thousand percent disgusting
and child abuse i've just thrown up in
my own mouth
it is disgusting in child abuse but i
have to say um not to be
play semantics here but i'm interested
in your use of the word
own i've just thrown up in my own mouth
in who and who else's mouth would you
throw up in i guess is my question
don't answer that rod royale says ipas
are for the pretentious
miller lite actually tastes great
it doesn't taste like anything what do
you mean it tastes great so
i don't get this this thing you hear
from people i it's a pretentious to
drink an ip
so flavor is pretentious beer is
supposed to have flavor that's why it
exists
so it's pretentious for a thing to
actually perform its intended function
you're saying is it pretentious for a
car
to start when you turn the ignition
do you get mad when your car starts and
you say man this thing is so pretentious
calm down car what are you trying to
prove here
that's why beer exists at least it's one
of the reasons that's why i drink it
because it tastes great
miller light it's not even that it
tastes bad it has no taste at all
um spencer says small families are not
happier in any way
i was an only child my parents were not
happy and i was pretty lonely i have
made it one of my most important life
goals to have at least three kids i have
one already and we'll have another two
if possible megan and harry can go to
hell
uh yeah i i look any size
family can be happy but the idea that
you maximize happiness in a family by
having fewer kids
is absurd and finally scott says
day 100 of begging matt to play the
banjo for us
well scott i know i did promise i do i
remember my promises and i know i
promised
and you've been putting this in the
comments for 100 days and i promised a
while ago
that if you keep this going for 100 days
i will play the banjo
and i am a man of my word
i have a few moments we are running a
little bit behind but um
i have a few moments so
i can now play you a little ditty on the
banjo
as an avid banjo player myself i do this
all the time
that all the offices here are constantly
filled with the noise of me the
beautiful sounds of me playing the banjo
because i'm such an avid banjo player
um but before i play i just gotta make
sure i get this thing tuned
like so we only have a couple of a
moment or two but i'll just let me get
this thing tuned and i'll play something
for you
just got to make sure i obviously know
how to tune a banjo because i play
banjo so often okay i think that's tuned
um then you just want it you want to tap
on it make sure there's nothing inside
it like any small animals
no okay
just give it a sniff make sure it's
still good
you know hasn't been left out in the sun
or anything and let me just get it tuned
real quick again let's make sure i tune
it
um because i look
i made a promise i'm gonna keep my
promise
okay i think it's tuned um
yep feels right let me tune it again
all right and uh uh well
yeah actually it's we just ran out of
time i'm sorry i i only had a few
moments
and we just ran out of time i got to
move on to the next segment i really i
really wanted to play it i was going to
play it
uh it was my plan but we just ran out of
time
i think that qualifies though as keeping
my promises which i always do
you know if candace frequents anything
it's the trending sidebar on twitter
and her own show uh which is good that
she frequents her own show you know i've
found generally you want to make sure
that you're frequenting your shows
i'm just reading a copy that's what they
told me to say and i'm saying it i'm a
parrot i just read what's put in front
of me
whether she's calling donald trump uh or
joking with adam corolla or sitting down
with mma fighter
beneal darish to discuss the marxist
ideology his family is fleeing from you
can be sure
any time spent watching candace is time
well spent she will be there she'll be
frequenting but she'll also be offering
her opinions which are always very
interesting
her latest episode dropped this week so
if you haven't tuned in yet i highly
recommend that you do you can watch
candace live
every day uh rather every tuesday at 9
00 pm eastern 8 pm central only on
dailywire.com
candace uh i don't know about you but uh
i for one
love my freedom even though i'm an
authoritarian
theocratic fascist i enjoy my own
freedom at least
i in no way intend to allow an
authoritarian dictator to take it from
me and to replace it with baseless
lockdown measures or the indoctrination
of my children into a leftist cult
and neither should you and that's why
ben shapiro wrote the authoritarian
moment because if we want to
shut down this ideology that that uh
precedes an authoritarian government we
need to
help every american understand as much
as they can about how we reach this
point
and then really importantly how we can
actually fight back what can we do
going forward so unless you want to live
under an authoritarian regime intent on
decreasing your freedom and increasing
their power it's time to start fighting
back get the authoritarian moment
and you could do that by pre-ordering on
amazon now or barnes noble or
any other major bookseller to get your
copy
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know we have on the show reviewed
many different types of tick-tock videos
which
i'm sure you've noticed and are grateful
for but the one genre we haven't spent
much time on
is abortion tick tock it's mostly for my
own sanity and emotional health that
i've avoided
wading into these waters and yet i find
that i can no longer avoid it especially
as i so often see these videos posted on
twitter or facebook
by people who sincerely believe that
some sort of brilliant and unanswerable
argument
has been presented so for our daily
cancellation today we're going to play
some of these clips
and respond to them now there are many
abortion related videos on the platform
where women simply brag about their own
abortions and pretend to think that it's
funny that they've just murdered their
own child
those are horrifying and sad and
infuriating and evil
but there isn't much else to say about
them and certainly no reason to play
them
it's no mystery why a woman might react
that way to her abortion it's a
rationalization
it's a defense mechanism these are women
who've done a horrible thing and they
know they've done a horrible thing at
some level they know it
and now they're overcompensating because
people who are happy about the decisions
they make
don't have to make videos convincing
strangers that they're happy about their
decisions as a general rule
now it may be true that some of these
women have successfully deluded
themselves
but that only lasts so long the fact is
despite what lies the abortion industry
tells
abortion is not the undoing of a
pregnancy it's not a reset or reverse
button
allowing you to go back to being a happy
carefree childless person
in pregnancy you become a mother
in abortion you become the mother of a
dead child
so there's a loss there's an absence
and you will feel it eventually that's a
fact
so all of the the the videos you see i'm
so happy about it
these are people who have deluded
themselves and that's all that is but
let's move on to the actual arguments
we're going to play a few videos here of
people on tick tock
presenting their best arguments for
abortion and let's start with this one
if a 16 year old wanted to adopt a child
the government wouldn't allow it she
isn't done with her education she isn't
financially
stable yet and she isn't a legal adult
but if she gets pregnant the government
can
ban her from getting an abortion
how is that logical
a few issues here first of all 16 year
olds are not banned from getting
abortions so yes
the whole premise of this argument is
wrong um
they're not 16 year olds can get
abortions
uh unfortunately they can get abortions
though in some states they need parental
consent
in other states they don't need parental
consent at all they just walk in and get
the abortion
so no need to worry ma'am your dreams
have come true teenage girls can kill
their babies
and are killing their babies so your
utopia is a reality congratulations
let's pretend that you're correct for a
moment let's pretend that 16 year olds
can't adopt which they can't and also
can't get abortions
and you think there's there's some kind
of conflict between these two
propositions you ask how this would be
logical well
let me tell you because the common
thread is one of mental competence
maturity
a 16 year old isn't mentally competent
enough to adopt she also isn't mentally
competent enough
to make the decision to take someone's
life
that's a bit of a misnomer because
nobody should be able to do that there's
no level of mental competence that
should permit you to kill a baby
even so abortion is a choice which has a
profound
impact on two lives at least
her own as the mother and the life of
her child which she is ending
i would call that a profound impact is a
16 year old
old enough to analyze those
ramifications and make a properly
informed choice
no but then if she doesn't have the
abortion she'll be a mother you say
you know so so what about that no you're
wrong
she's already a mother as we have
previously established she's a mother at
conception
the human has been conceived that's done
that part is over
completed fulfilled the question is what
to do
about this child or with this child
you say she isn't old enough to care for
the child so
what she's old enough to kill it i say
that's insane and morally grotesque and
evil
and also illogical instead we could try
to find someone who can care for the
child if she can't
and and and by the way we hear about
the bad the you know kids who are up for
adoption and they can't find anyone to
adopt them
and okay well it sounds so easy you put
the child up for adoption with a baby
for adoption there's going to be in the
system forever and no one's going to
adopt them
that's not true okay now it is true
sadly and tragically that um older kids
who end up in the system
oftentimes it's very difficult to find a
family that will take them in
that's a terrible thing that is not the
case for babies
there is a waiting list a million miles
long
of families waiting to adopt babies
so a 16 year old can't has a baby
can't care for the baby you put that
that child up for adoption
and he will be adopted by a loving
family
very quickly one other thought though
you don't think 16 year olds are old
enough to be parents okay uh
are they old enough to choose their
gender what do you think about that
i think i already know your answer let's
watch another and see if these
arguments get any better let's talk
about abortion and specifically the
heartbeat bill when someone gets in an
accident and they're considered brain
dead
no one considers it morally wrong to
pull that person's plug or in their life
because although that person has a
beating heart they aren't a conscious
being they have no brain activity
here's another example why do most
people not consider it morally wrong to
kill an
insect but do consider it morally wrong
to kill a cat or a dog
they both have beating hearts the
difference between the two
is level of consciousness a dog is very
aware of its existence and creates
relationships with the things around
them
whereas an insect just lives off of
instinct they aren't aware that they
exist they just do
the thing i'm really confused about is
why all of a sudden when it comes to
abortion
we allow a beating heart to signify life
when in all other aspects of our life
a beating heart doesn't mean anything
what matters is level of consciousness
and the fetus in the first trimester
does not have consciousness
i don't know where to begin here she's
built a tower of false assumptions and
baseless assertions all resting on a
false premise taped up with red herrings
and non-sequiturs
so let's run through some things very
quickly number one you have no idea how
much
consciousness a quote fetus possesses
number two you have no idea if a dog
is aware of its existence i doubt that
it is personally does
does a dog have an eye concept is it
aware of itself
as an eye a self can a dog
think to itself and and and and can
think oh
i am doing this i am doing that
i doubt it we could debate that but
nobody really knows number three you say
heartbeat doesn't matter in any other
area of life really so it's all about
consciousness so you're arguing that
it should be considered morally
permissible to kill anything that is not
conscious
or that we assume isn't conscious okay
then how would you feel if i went and
chopped down 100 trees for no reason
let's start with that what if i captured
a thousand eagles and shot them all
and threw their bodies in a dumpster how
would you how would that rub you
are eagles more conscious than unborn
children i don't think so
four if consciousness is the measure of
worth then what about levels of
consciousness among
and within born humans consciousness is
not
one set thing there are degrees of it
a one-year-old is conscious but
certainly is less aware than a
ten-year-old
does a ten-year-old then possess more
moral worth what about a 30 year old as
compared to an 85 year old dementia
patient
so you've created this scale of worth
this way of measuring things
and i don't think you've thought about
where it leads or maybe you have which
is even worse
number five here's a big one important
point even if i agreed with your whole
premise and all of your assertions which
i don't
you've got a major problem the unborn
child unlike the brain dead person or
the insect
is only in this limited conscious state
temporarily
we know that he will soon have more
consciousness he is headed towards that
point
with every passing second inevitably if
you leave him to his own devices
so what if we knew take the brain dead
person
what if we knew that person would wake
up in three weeks
still okay to kill them so that's the
real analogy here
a person with limited mental functioning
who we know for a fact
will soon have full mental functioning
in any other context would you say that
it's okay to exploit that limited window
of reduced consciousness
and kill the person but he's not
conscious right now let's kill him
but that's bad news for anyone who's
ever i don't know gone to sleep
let's try one more video do
conservatives realize
that by banning abortion their taxes are
going to go up
by a lot rich women will always have
access to abortion no matter what the
law is they will always be able to get
it
so forcing poor women to have children
that they cannot afford
even in the cases of rape and incest
means the state has to pay for it
meaning your tax dollars
romania's welfare system completely
collapsed when they banned abortion in
the 70s
and at that time their population was
about 20 million
texas has a population of 29 million
wow mic drop mind blown
taxes will go up do i realize that taxes
will go up if abortion is man here's a
better question
um do i give a damn see i i'm not sure
if your assumptions are actually true or
not the taxes will go up but
but if they are who cares do you realize
that the whole point of the pro-life
cause the whole argument we're making is
that human life has objective and
inherent value
our point is that a human's value is not
contingent on how convenient that life
is to those around it
if we believe that we'd be pro-abortion
like you but we don't so we're not
so if taxes go up because abortion is
banned
okay i don't like paying taxes but i'm
not going to support
mass slaughter and genocide just to
avoid it
i mean we could also reduce our taxes by
just killing everybody on welfare right
now
does that strike you see i'm not a
murderous sociopath who reduces human
life down to a matter of mere dollars
and cents
that's not my gig that's not my stance
it's yours remember so speak for
yourself
or better yet stop speaking because you
and the rest of abortion tick tock
are today absolutely cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director
is austin stevens production manager
pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
dr fauci recommends that three-year-olds
mask up
drug overdose deaths hit the highest
level ever recorded according to the cdc
and the feds spend a fortune prosecuting
the horn guy
from the capital riot check it out on
the michael knowles show